i want to make a quick clarification
based on the last video in the last
video we compared fractions for example
we cared compared four sevens to three
sevenths and we saw clearly four
sevenths is a larger fraction of the
whole than three sevenths was but you
might say hey but what if what if my
whole was bigger what if i took 3 7 of
this big thing here then 3 7 would look
like this so it would be 1
sevenths and so this three sevenths this
looks like i have filled in more than i
would have over here for the three for
the four seven so doesn't it matter
which hole you're taking the fraction of
and the answer is yes it does matter and
you when you compare fractions you
assume that you're taking fractions of
the same whole so you can only make this
comparison right over here so it has to
be let me make this very clear it has to
be the same
it has to be the same
the same hole that you're making the
comparison you can't compare 4 7 of a
mouse to 3 7 of an elephant those are
two different things you cannot make
that comparison you could compare four
sevens of a mouse to three sevenths of
that same house or a mouse the same size
then you could make the same comparison
when we talk about fractions as just
pure numbers then we're then we
automatically go to the number line
the hole that we talk about when we're
on the number line is the section of our
number line between zero and one
so that makes it
so this is zero and then this is one
here when we talk about fractions it's
just pure numbers we're not saying
four-sevenths of a mouse or
four-sevenths of an elephant we're just
talking about a number on the number
line and so we would split this into
sevenths let me see if i could do that
let me draw
so that's one seventh two sevenths
three sevens four
five
six and that's seven sevenths right over
there or one so this is
seven sevenths or one and this right
over here is 1 7
2 7
3 7
4 7
5 7 whoops 5 7
and 6 7. and so when you look at the
number line here it's clear that three
sevenths which is three jumps from zero
three jumps of a seventh each one
two three
three sevenths puts you right there
while four sevenths is a larger number
it's to the right of three sevenths you
have to make four jumps one
two three
four four jumps of a seventh to get
right over there so you can make this
comparison as long as you're doing it
you're looking at the fraction of the
same hole here the same hole is the
region of our number line between zero
and one
in the previous video the same hole was
this yellow bar you can't compare four
sevenths of this yellow bar to three
sevenths of this much larger blue bar